good morning John I have been known to
go to a sports game and sometimes during
them I will be having a particularly
good time watching people do
extraordinary athletic things and I'll
be taken by the urge to just say yell
like sports I do this kind of
half-and-half II in a way that I don't
like in the moment realize like half of
it is I am having an enthusiastically
good time with this minor league
baseball game and this hot dog is
excellent and the other half is like I
am an intellectual and so while I am
enjoying this I am enjoying it somewhat
separately and from an anthropological
perspective not like all these normal
people which is of course upon
reflection crappy I'm not being too hard
on myself here mostly I recognize that
the sports games I go to are not super
easy to take seriously like all of the
Missoula Bruins are much better hockey
players than I am but they're also
mostly teenagers it's not like I'm at an
NFL game with the pop and the fireworks
and the triple digit ticket prices
sometimes I think the Bruins would pay
me to go as long as I sign up to buy a
certain amount of personal pan pizzas I
enjoy enjoying things but I do have
still a little bit of that sports are
dumb mentality leftover from when I was
socially discounted and occasionally
punched by athletic people when I was
myself a team this is understandable but
it becomes a bit more of a problem when
you rationalize that perspective because
really it's born in like I'm not gonna
like the things that the people who
don't like me like but instead of
admitting why you're actually
uninterested which is that you've been
kind of socially excluded from enjoying
this thing you end up with some
half-assed argument about how oh it's so
exciting that a hockey puck gets to be
beyond the geometrically defined plane
of the place where you don't want the
hockey puck to go woo everybody's
celebrating such an intellectual I
understand where true meaning actually
comes from which is duh oh shoot all
value is bestowed by humans so when we
say it matters that the ball went
through the hoop it matters if that
makes you uncomfortable I wouldn't look
too long at anything but I will admit
coming into your video a certain lack of
interest in the World Cup though by the
end of the video I had a lot of
questions that I was very curious about
particularly while the team seemed to
have eleven people except for the
Russian team which was like 26 also why
did that video which made me laugh so
hard I peed alittle not get more view
and I think maybe part of that is that
nerdfighters are probably a little bit
more
likely to be like me then like you when
it comes to sports enthusiasm but as the
one who was a little bit perplexed by
the fanaticism of sports fans I want to
make a case for the World Cup caring
about stuff is good and having passions
that you share with people who are
otherwise somewhat dissimilar from you
is maybe even better and the thing about
the World Cup
unlike saved the world series which will
maybe occasionally have a Canadian team
in it it really is a World Cup soccer
and I apologize for using that word but
I am deeply American is a world sport in
the same way that the US and Russia and
a bunch of other countries can work
together on a space station and maybe
that is an even loftier thing than the
science that gets done there one month
every two years the whole world works
together to figure out who's best at a
dumb game but honestly maybe there isn't
anything less dumb than this we have
these tribal instincts and so finding
ways to focus them on something that
isn't violent but instead it's beautiful
it's a celebration of human skill and
intellect and hard work and perseverance
in other words it's a celebration of a
bunch of stuff that pretty much
everybody can get on board for there's
an equality of the pitch an opportunity
for nations to interact in a way that
doesn't have anything to do with the
fraught mess of geopolitics World Cup
matters so much without mattering too
much at least to most people so what I'm
saying is maybe sports are dumb maybe
that's the whole reason why sports
aren't dumb John I'll see you on Tuesday
three things oh my god have got to be at
VidCon a week from now just uploaded a
video on Hanks channel about why I used
to play hockey and we just relaunched a
new design of dftba.com and I'm so happy
about it